Oh
don't they're good God talk about a
kid's dream come true not only were you
supposed to get as messy as possible but
you are also supposed to get your
brother your sister and even your
parents messy all while winning fabulous
prizes if you somehow worked dinosaurs
and outerspace into it you would have
every kid's equivalent of heaven
this show is ingenious and I mean
ingenious double there was incredible
like the world's greatest Japanese game
show except nobody dies with an idea so
inspired you have to wonder how anybody
could possibly think it up well my
thought is it wants something like this
and thus Doubleday was born the first
show that literally taught us fuckin I
want to get dirty now for those of you
who don't know the rules of the show it
went something like this
two teams usually made up of a family of
four had to answer a series of questions
that were kind of like Trivial Pursuit
for dummies an Encino man what actor
plays the caveman oh wait that was on
Final Jeopardy last night if the family
doesn't know the answer they say they're
if the other family doesn't know the
answer
they say double dare and thus the only
option left is the physical challenge
now the physical challenge is what
everyone remembers this is where you
have to do something really messy and
really sloppy in order to earn extra
points
they were always strange wacky and
incredibly disgusting and God how we
love it and part of the funnel it's just
how strange and weird these physical
challenges were I mean that's got to be
the greatest job in the world to come up
with those games can you imagine what
the creative process for this must have
been like I see hands they're puppy
balloons that are filled with chitti
leave their hands aren't attached to you
know their arms like you would me
they're attached to their heads
I see bananas little man who's driving
the bananas and other bananas you have
to put ice cream and chocolate because
they're trying to make a banana split or
drive me bananas okay anyone in the mood
for tacos
now cheese tomatoes whatever comes first
now after you go through the fiscal
challenges the family with the most
points gets to go through the obstacle
course and this is by far the best part
of a show you had to go through all
these insane contraptions and grab the
flag at the end of each one some of
these obstacles included inside out down
the hatch and the sundae slide now
unfortunately they didn't go through
with all of the obstacle course
selections that they came up with such
as team world or a fun slide of thorns
river of acid and probably the most
controversial of all crucifixion ah but
hey that's not to say they were all
family-friendly I mean look at some of
these obstacles they look like medieval
tortures created by both of the clown
and some of them were just downright
cruel like remember trying to find the
flag and the peanut butter and jelly
sandwich how the fuck he's supposed to
find anything in that shit this was
always like the hardest one and yet it
was always like the second obstacle half
the time they couldn't even get to the
other obstacles because they were too
busy looking for that damn flag
sometimes it could be very amusing or
how about the near misses where the flag
just barely slips out of the players
hand oh come on you dicks just give him
the Porsche well either way it was fun
to watch but I doubt it was fun to taste
I mean what is half of that stuff for
all we know that could be like toxic
waste or something one of mother
nature's favorite little gifts whatever
it was it was slippery I don't know if
they wax the floors with banana peels or
what the people were falling and
breaking bones like crazy Oh
this place is like a lawsuit factory now
that you may have noticed that people
didn't exactly get a lot of money on the
show I mean look at this I think the
highest I ever saw go up to with 700
bucks or something that'll barely pay
for the dry cleaning but the point of
the show wasn't really to win money it
was just to have fun I need you imagine
if they did hand out big money on this
show my guess is there will be a lot
more swearing all right get in there get
in there
no no you don't listen to me come on get
in there I just can't do it keep your
head up
keep your fucking head up I'm fine no we
need that money for grandmas operation
we wouldn't want that to happen now
would actually some of these people did
take this show very seriously I mean
look at them some of them don't even
crack a smile okay dude this is not an
extreme sport okay you're at a salad
bowl for God's sake well let me assure
you we are still crazy now the host of
this show is probably the greatest game
show host that ever walked the planet
Marc summers why is he so great a couple
of reasons first of all he has to talk
about total nonsense throughout the
entire show and make it sound like it's
intense TV I mean how much can you talk
about half of this stuff yeah they get
the no condoms
some saucers the attack oh you gotta get
back at your taco
how many gameshow hosts are there that
can actually with all seriousness say
get back in your taco second he gets
just as into the show as the rest of the
audience screaming and yelling and even
getting messy sometimes
third and definitely not least this guy
was obsessive-compulsive you heard right
obsessive compulsive that means he liked
everything clean neat and symmetrical oh
my god that is total devotion to your
work I mean look at all this they went
through his house and moved around a few
things and there he is down on the floor
straightening the rug moving the chairs
fixing the curtains I mean this is how
bad he was OCD is all about compulsive
rituals and mind were about cleanliness
and making things symmetrical and this
guy had to do double dare the sloppiest
and messiest game show that ever aired
on TV give this man a fucking medal I'm
serious dude if you can't find a medal
to fit the situation make one up
in fact I'll make one up March summers
on behalf of children everywhere I give
you the honorary dude you got balls
award you deserved it man you deserved
it I mean look at this shit that they
put in true do you even think they knew
he had a problem
nobody did he just stuck it through like
a true professional actually it is kind
of funny watching this knowing what we
know now that playful laugh suddenly
sounds like a cry for help
want me to be a doctor with a great host
a great premise and a great big Lotus
line Doubleday was by far one of the
coolest game shows that ever graced the
airwaves and was one of the trademarks
that helped make Nickelodeon a household
name double dare
oh my fuckin decency these double dare
the show that only pleases it is double
dare get drowned in several pieces it is
double dare
oh my god it's double dare I don't
beware double dare it gets in your hair
double dare and everywhere it is a hold
there holy shit it's double dare I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember so you don't
have to balls
in Encino man what actor plays the
caveman polisher no it's not Pauly Shore
this person has talent